hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to knockout city the
dodgeball game
and that's it this video is brought to
you by the epic game story you can use
my code my creator code
my code of creators my code of creators
markiplier on the epic game store with
your purchases to support
to support me this is awful this is
terrible you can get knockout city right
now to try it out for yourself or you
can wait until after i
play the game and then you can see for
yourself all right so the basic
principle is about the same as any other
i actually have never played
this so i don't know why i'm speaking
like an authority on this uh it's like
dodgeball you remember dodgeball
the horribly dramatic experience tackle
yeah okay tackle i didn't know that that
was a part of
dodgeball but apparently yes get off the
building
i've killed them
i killed them this is a bomb
it's just a bomb that's just a bomb
all right it is a bomb
[Music]
man i'm pretty good i'm not gonna lie
i'm pretty good
all right let's get in a match and let's
see what happens because i'm probably
going to suck anyway
or i'm going to be amazing or i'm
probably going to suck how do i do this
left all the ball up
you'll never catch me
he'll never catch me
yeah that makes sense contracts
didn't i complete training did i not
complete training
who needs training training's for losers
let's just go to
play 3v3 man i'm going to let my
team down i was hoping for like a big 10
v10 but let's do a 3v3
we'll see what happens probably nothing
impressive or maybe it will be
but i'll always have lixie in there to
make it look impressive no matter what
right lexian
you'll cut it together to make it look
like i win every time right oh
okay we're starting okay this is for
real this time i don't know how to catch
who needs training training's for losers
[Music]
i actually don't remember how to catch
another i never learned so i can't even
remember
i'll be here playing the hits and
calling the shots
okay so bomb ball so threat of death
right
i was up why do i look different than
everybody why do i am i default or am i
special
round one okay
i literally have no idea how to play i
literally don't know
oh god there's a ball
okay let's try this oh no that's not
right
i get it whoa okay well that's not good
okay so i failed at first and i don't
even know what i failed at
that would be a ball i mean that would
be a bomb
well i do want to murder someone take
some of this
yeah you get that whatever that happened
okay i'm assuming we're not gold team
and i'm assuming that walking out of the
bounds would be pretty bad
oh right click of course yeah that would
make sense
where's a ball there's no balls
perfect exactly what i was hoping for
oh no oh no
somehow that worked i'm not sure how
oh i'm fine i can make it
that's a bowl i like balls okay
take some of that and one of these
oh i can make it
oh no no no we're not falling way behind
you're falling way behind
i'm falling to the way
okay ambush time
oh yes we are the greatest
the best that has ever lived let's do
this
mad kahuna ow what did
the
i got a knockout though i did get a
knockout i think i think that count
unless they got their own teammate and
looks like friendly fire is on
okay five to eight that's not terrible
but i feel like we're about to lose
get out there yeah yeah i tackled you
oh my god it took a little bit to get
used to this to get to the use do this
yeah we are yeah we are come on let's do
this
squad and go squad don't do it
you would never there we go
ah not today
yeah oh sorry oh sorry i'm sorry
next point wins oh my god
oh no no you don't no you know
ah that's sad well i did okay
that was pretty that was very fun i
actually really like that
oh there's a match okay we really caught
up towards the end there
like we really caught up i don't know
how i'm doing to be perfectly honest
but uh it seems like i'm doing a okay
i'm having fun and isn't that what it's
all about if my teammates aren't happy
about me having fun then aren't they
just a bunch of a-holes
gold team takes the lead
oh well hello no you don't
catch miss me you'll never
who are you who am i
no you don't ah you missed
ah no you don't no you don't get out of
here
oh you want some oh knocked you out
gold team takes the lead
oh i mean goofed
but i think i got didn't i did i knock
that other guy out on the other side
over there
i might have all tied up baby all tied
up i got to get used to all the double
jumping
on the hoodie whampin
yes let's together on this who's alive
of course we do of course we do hey
what's up hey what's up
oh yay you'll never try me try me
do it do it do me do me do me ah oh i
caught it
i pushed the button i don't know how the
catch works if i have to like time it or
something
oh yeah yeah do me got it let's
point for you out wonk
oh come on try me try me who's who's
going
you got it no
try me do me oh
oh you will you'll never you'll never
never i will never go down ha ha
try me i don't know what that's all
about
yes i somehow survived all of that
can i have this i love this thank you
hey look take one
that was my bad that was my bad that was
my bad
that was my bad that was my bad look i'm
really not doing my team justice here
but i
i did survive for that long long time
look both ways before crossing the
railroad
hey you leave my buddy alone
mine mine mine
[Music]
i mean an assist but
it all comes down to this if we win this
round
i don't know what voice that was this is
very fun
i haven't played dodgeball in ages i
remember the last time i played
dodgeball i got hit in the face and then
these two girls that were like
not playing at all you know they were
leaning up against the back wall they
laughed at me
because i got hit in the face and then
while they were laughing
one of them got hit in the face
so i justifiably laughed back at them
in a really exaggerated way you're like
but you know it felt justified like the
universe was definitely on my side in
that one
all right let's do this all right you
want to oh get that ball
come on get it get the bomb no oh
yeah well they got the bomb
there's a bomb this bomb
come on got it
ah come on oh but i could click the
thing
i click the thing i do i swear
oh i hear
got it that was a hit
yeah we do yeah we do of course we do
get some of that try it miss me
by that much this is what i call an
ambush
oh yes oh that was bad
that almost got me seven to four baby we
can't lose
how could we lose how could we lose
we could man that was from downtown
don't you dare where are they
oh who did that
oh yeah funkus hey my ball
hey my bomb okay i'll take it
i really don't know where they are
eight to six that's not terrible
oh no you know oh yeah you want to try
that again
well i'm dead so you can't joke's on you
joke's on you i can't let my team down i
got the team
on my shoulders i gotta carry us to
victory
i gotta bring us to the bread
yeah we do of course we do yeah
i was there when it happened i saw it
with my own eyes
get wrecked all of you suck i'm amazing
i don't want to look at the scoreboard
because it will distort my opinion of
what actually happened in this
never mind i'm the greatest that ever
existed
i'm the best that ever lived yes
yes i did i did it
i'm the winner i'm the win i won
i am the greatest i am the mvp
okay anyway i'm literally shaking i
can't really handle
competitive multiplayer stuff especially
when i get into it
i i literally like my hands are shaking
i
only have one adrenal gland right i had
i had an adrenal gland surgically
removed
and i don't know if the other one is
just like super compensating or
something
but like any time i get into like
competitive multiplayer i get like the
shakes like i get super sweats
you know what i mean i can't handle it
the pressure it's too much but this is
super duper fun i i think that i'm gonna
end it there just because like
i can't do any better i must have been
playing with like some really bad people
but it makes me feel good
and i was the mvp and i'm never gonna
chase i'm never gonna get that high if i
keep playing i'm just gonna chase this
high forever
but you can play this game it's
available on the epic game store link in
the description below
once again this video is brought to you
by the epic game store use my creator
code markiplier
to support me on the epic game store
with whatever purchase you have if you
put in my creative court it helps me out
thank you very much everybody for
watching
uh do play this game because it is very
fun and uh
yeah if you see me in the game you'll
know that i'm
literally trembling with excitement so
thank you
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
now was i recording yes i was